our planet has survived billions of
years of catastrophic events that made
it the world we live on now
but one day there will be an event so
disastrous that it will destroy this
floating rock and end this experiment
known as humanity
and after the lengthy number of
possibilities we've narrowed down our
list to the top five earth-shattering
events
would we be sucked into an endless void
could a second star appear and fry our
planet
or is death waiting just below earth's
crust
you better get to the bunker because
here are the top five craziest events
that could end the world
whether it was the breakup of pangaea or
the meteor that took out the dinosaurs
earth has been through more than one
apocalyptic event these events changed
our planet's geography while ushering in
new ages for the life forms that
followed
and that's usually been at the expense
of the creatures who were already here
but
somewhere in our planet's future lies an
extinction event so devastating that it
might not simply take out all of
humanity
but the earth as well
and in a matter of time our world
could return to dust
so
what would it take to rip apart the
earth completely
stargazing can bring a sense of wonder
that calms your mind but that may be
over now because that shooting star you
spotted isn't here to grant your wish
you may want a duck
hurricanes remain one of the most deadly
natural events on our planet and they
leave a trail of death and destruction
wherever they land
but if an asteroid hits an ocean with
enough force and heat
hurricanes would be like fluff balls
compared to what would come next
a big enough asteroid would super heat
the oceans to over 49 degrees
and this could set off a massive storm
known as a hypercane
winds would move as fast as the speed of
sound and clouds would reach heights of
up to 40 kilometers
the winds would shoot water and aerosols
into the stratosphere destroying the
ozone layer
so
even if the winds didn't carry you into
space
you could get fried by the radiation on
earth's surface
this gas giant has twice the mass of all
the planets in our solar system combined
and the gases swirling around inside
jupiter's atmosphere are the same
materials that make up the sun
but if jupiter became 1 000 times more
massive
that distant yellow dot would wreak
havoc on our planet
with that much mass jupiter would turn
into a star
since this new star would be right in
the middle of the solar system planetary
bodies would change their orbits
earth could get pulled in closer to
jupiter and get scorched by the heat
coming off the former planet
or even worse gravitational forces could
make our world a rogue planet
that means we'd be sent away into space
outside the solar system
endlessly roaming the universe in search
of a new home
without the heat of the sun to keep us
warm the surface of the earth would
freeze over killing all life on our
planet
[Music]
but maybe we shouldn't focus on a star
that hasn't formed yet and concentrate
on the one we have
after all this ball of gas makes life
possible on our planet but since it
burns through 600 million tons of
hydrogen every second it's only a matter
of time before this power source is used
up
and when that occurs the sun's core will
become saturated with helium and begin
to shrink
the increased pressure and temperature
would cause the sun to spit out massive
amounts of energy
the sun's outer layers would expand
creating a deadly heat wave on earth
our oceans would evaporate into thin air
and the radiation would scorch the
planet's surface
finally the sun once the giver of life
would swallow up what's left of our
molten planet
and if the sun keeps expanding
our solar system would face a new threat
oh man it just keeps getting worse
[Music]
if the sun gains even more mass before
collapsing you could witness the birth
of one of the most mysterious forces in
the universe
a black hole
the product of a dying star the
gravitational pull of this void can rip
apart other stars and planets
right now the sun is too small to create
one of these catastrophes but if a black
hole appears in front of earth
the uneven gravitational pull would
start deforming the planet
earthquakes and volcanic eruptions would
break out all over the planet and as you
come closer to the black hole's event
horizon this monster might stretch out
this world like a rubber band
a black hole sucks in matter by
compressing it horizontally making it
look like a noodle we call this
spaghettification
every bit of our planet would be
stretched into a string of atoms and fed
into this hungry void
do you think earth's future couldn't get
any worse
well come on this is what if and
right now 10 to 20 volcanoes are
erupting across our planet spewing ash
and gas into the atmosphere
but if every volcano on earth exploded
at once
you couldn't escape the fumes and heat
no matter where you live
rocks reaching 1 000 degrees would
travel as fast as 700 kilometers per
hour
with such a massive amount of molten
rock slamming onto the surface
the planet could lose its balance and
the poles could realign
a thick layer of ash and gas would
suffocate earth and eventually block out
all the sunlight
and
while the lava cools
the temperature on earth would
drastically drop sending us into another
ice age
while this event wouldn't necessarily
end our entire planet
it would destroy any chance of
sustaining life until those clouds clear
up
life on earth has ended several times
before and it's safe to say it will
happen again
think you're prepped for these scenarios
let us know in the comments
of course we based these doomsday
predictions around science and
observable facts but some things are
beyond our understanding like
what if the threat to our existence
wasn't miles underground
what if it was less than two meters
below
what if there was a zombie apocalypse
well start working on your cardio
because that's a story
for another
what if